in der u bahnstation helden der arbeit
im norden von hartz iv drängen an
normalen tagen hunderte passagiere es
ist laut und hektisch doch seit 84 tagen
ist stille die metrostationen der stadt
dienen seit dem 24 februar als
schutzräume noch immer leben hier 550
menschen mehrere meter unterhalb der
erde irgendwo ein kleines bisschen
privatsphäre finden fast aussichtslos
und so markieren die matratzen den
umfang der eigenen bleibe die luft ist
kalt und feucht wer glück hat hat eine
warme decke mitgenommen auf der flucht
hierhin in den schützenden untergrund im
dritten waggon am ende des bahnsteigs
hat sich familie die schenkung
einquartiert seit 25 februar sind die
vier hier unten nikita ist 12 deine
schwester anja fünf jahre alt beide sind
krank von der feuchtigkeit und der
schlechten luft dutzende von stofftieren
sollen das gefühl von zuhause vermitteln
an einem ort der das nicht sein kann was
soll ich sagen sie spielen manchmal mit
anderen kindern schauen
zeichentrickfilme und wenn es ruhig ist
gehen wir vielleicht ganz kurz raus
ansonsten versuchen wir es uns so häufig
wie möglich zu machen wäsche waschen
putzen essen nur kaffee ist wie fühlst
du dich hier unmodisch nach ich habe
mich daran gewöhnt ein ganz normales
leben
die angst vor den russischen
bombenangriffen hat sie hierhin
getrieben sie mussten alles zurücklassen
und nun sind sie schon so lange hier
dass die fünfjährige ist bereits als
normal empfindet
eigentlich müssen wir uns selbst um das
essen kümmern
aber manchmal bekommen wir auch etwas
von hilfsorganisationen geliefert
suppen oder ähnliches
wir haben hier jedenfalls keine
möglichkeit selbst zu kochen
[Musik]
sie leben weitgehend in der dunkelheit
des schachts es gibt nur die
öffentlichen toiletten die von hunderten
menschen genutzt werden richtig waschen
konnten sie sich schon lange nicht mehr
und obwohl die sehnsucht nach zuhause
groß ist trauen sich viele noch nicht
zurück
über der erde liegt ihre stadt in
trümmern 30 prozent aller gebäude sind
beschädigt oder zerstört
wochenlang war jeder schritt in der
stadt gefährlich menschen wurden auf dem
weg zum wasser kaufen von russischen
bomben getötet seit einer woche ist es
nun ruhiger geworden doch normalität
gibt es nicht mehr viele menschen haben
ihre bleibe und ihre existenz verloren
und doch sind alle entschlossen zum
widerstand dieses video von ukrainischen
soldaten die bis an die russische grenze
vorgedrungen sind wird in allen sozialen
medien geteilt es macht vielen in hartz
iv hoffnung und zuversicht dass sie ihr
land gegen die truppen putins
verteidigen können hier haben die
ukrainischen soldaten sie verdrängt
das restaurant 450 war vor dem krieg ein
beliebter treffpunkt in kharkiv
jetzt ist hier eine suppenküche
170 freiwillige darunter 67 köche haben
sich zusammengetan um die bedürftigen
aus den dörfern rund um proaktiv zu
versorgen
riskiert dafür sein leben sie tragen
schusssichere westen denn jeder zeit
können neue raketen einschlagen für
helme haben sie kein geld 8 uhr zeigt
uns ein gebäude das er und andere
freiwillige bis vor kurzem noch als
verteilzentrum genutzt haben zweimal
haben die russen es gezielt bombardiert
sie wollen der zivilen bevölkerung so
viel angst wie möglich machen damit
freiwillige und helfer ihre arbeit
einstellen wir haben aber keine angst
alle freiwilligen und ich setzen unsere
arbeit fort
die not in den dörfern ist groß wochen
lang waren sie abgeschnitten von der
außenwelt die lebensmittel gingen
irgendwann aus
12.000 menschen versorgt acht chance
organisation in diesen tagen mit frisch
gekochtem essen
8 jung arbeitet bis zur erschöpfung
er will so vielen menschen wie möglich
helfen
die menschen tun mir leid ich würde
gerne mehr für sie tun aber rein
körperlich schaffe ich es nicht wenn wir
zusätzliche helfer hätten eine zweite
küche und mehr treibstoff
dann könnten wir mehr tun es gibt aber
so gut wie nirgends mehr tankstellen die
offen haben und autoersatzteile wären
auch nicht schlecht im moment versuchen
wir sie selbst zu reparieren sie sind
alt zum glück funktionieren sie
dann verabschiedet er sich von uns dort
wo er jetzt hinfährt soll die kamera
nicht mit zu groß die angst der menschen
dass das ihren aufenthaltsort verrät
zurück im u bahn schacht in kharkiv
nikita und anja treffen sich mit anderen
kindern in einer provisorischen spiele
ecke dort wo früher fahrkarten
kontrolliert wurden
psychologin lena lebt auch hier unten
und kümmert sich freiwillig um die
kinder doch die situation ist für alle
belastend
ich frage immer vorher die eltern ob ich
helfen kann und
eigentlich brauchen auch die eltern
psychologische betreuung vielleicht
sogar mehr als die kinder
seitdem fragt nicht mehr unter
dauerbeschuss ist wagen sich die ersten
heraus anja genießt den moment der
freiheit ganz alleine hockt sie sich an
die gleise um wilde blumen zu pflücken
eine kleine freude mein moment des
glücks in einer dunklen zeit
[Musik]